Target is a gay satanic church
now that's a big change that's what it
says uh right here you used to be a
store that's used to be a store but now
in 20163 based on the massive success of
their uh clothing lines featuring
satanic representations and Impressions
they follow the money and change their
business model turning uh the the former
retail giant into the largest and most
successful uh satanic Church on the
globe oh wow and uh off been Dawning a a
blood red top
hat but high priest Timothy shamay oh no
broadcasts his weekly satanic Target
sermons directly into the chipped brains
of members of the target death Circle
rewards
program